she's saying the value that she brings  to the man that is approaching her  whether he chooses to go to her or once  or 20 whatever obviously he's approached  her so he likes her so that's the value  that she brings that's that's the point  I'm saying I've never talked about you  guys I don't know  but the question is is that fair to  expect monogamy so I'm saying over a  certain age you're less valuable to man  and then as soon as I say as soon as I  say that you guys get triggered no no no  and you guys you keep you keep  interrupting this is this is this is  this is my this is she no no no I'm  saying  stop this is rude this is my show it's  very rude to interrupt the host okay  sorry sorry like this is disrespectful  sorry carry on and so I'm saying that if  you're going to men and telling them  what they should value and every time I  say this is what men value you guys you  keep arguing with it then you want to  say well what are my best years this  this and this okay